what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are officially into the
second prelude for the war of jokes and
riddles and again for those of you guys
who were just joining us the war of
jokes and riddles is this upcoming story
but everybody's really excited about
from Batman I'm really excited about it
because there's a story this basically
going to cover like the Joker and the
Riddler presumably fighting one another
but the whole idea is that the war of
jokes and riddles comes out of Batman
zero year and of course you'll find all
the Batman stuff and the playlist down
in the description as well as my main
page but to get you caught up a little
bit Batman zero year was basically DC's
way of telling the new origin of Batman
when the new 52 first launched down in
2011 and so the first story arc that we
covered in the last video was secret
city and it was basically just the
origin of the Joker but one of the
things that I did here's I actually left
out a tail end of the story and the
reason why is because that tail end
leads directly into this so I kind of
figured it would make more sense to kind
of tack it into this video as opposed to
the last video but the whole idea was
that in secret City Bruce Wayne was kind
of stepping into his role as Batman he
was still discovering what he was
capable of he was still discovering how
he needed a function accordingly how to
deal with criminals so on and so forth
it wasn't until about halfway through
that story that he actually donned the
Batman costume and became the Caped
Crusader that we all know and love the
issue with this is that eventually the
conflict led him into a battle with a
guy called the Red Hood and ultimately
resulted in the Red Hood falling into
the ACE chemical VAT now the reason why
this matters is because the Red Hood
falling into the chemical VAT at ace
chemicals it's kind of like this
hallmark origin of The Killing Joke
really one of the definitive origins of
the Joker and the one that people cite
the most often when they're talking
about the Joker's origin the idea and
one of the things we left out but I
wanted hack into this video it's
following the events of this guy falling
into you know the Red Hood falling into
this chemical that once they went
through and tried to discover the body
there was no one there and so this
really seemed to hint towards the notion
of the original Killing Joke origin that
the Joker the guy who would become a
joker fell into the that eventually
escaped and then was driven insane by
his change in physical appearance
basically living up to the moniker from
that from that original story The
Killing Joke
all it takes is one bad day and so what
ended up happening here is they actually
discovered that there was a person who
was originally the leader of the Red
Hood
and this guy's name was Liam distil the
problem with this was that while he was
the original leader of the Red Hood gang
someone somewhere killed him threw his
body in lye so no one could determine
the time of death and so they don't know
if he was killed days weeks or months
before the entire battle at age chemical
meeting no one knows how long this
person who became the Joker was leading
the Red Hood gang and so again it was a
really really cool moment because it was
kind of like this wrench that we're
throwing in there and suddenly not
everything is what it appears to be and
so again it's a really cool moment but
the reason why I want to tack this into
this video is because while you know
Batman and while you know Alfred and so
on and so forth while they're all going
through and they're basically kind of
talking about the nature of Gotham City
and we're talking about Batman's role
using fear as it means to try to curb
violence The Riddler suddenly appears
now again the Riddler in the secret city
story was just a guy named Edward nygma
and that was his involvement in terms of
Gotham City was limited to the fact that
he was more of an advisor to Phillip
came the guy who took over as a head of
Wayne Enterprises following the death of
Bruce Wayne's parents but before Bruce
Wayne returned after all of his training
and martial arts and all that kind of
good stuff
and so the result was that following you
know basically Bruce Wayne taking or is
stepping back into his role as the head
of Wayne Enterprises Edward nygma
effectively vacated his position as
advisor and then this is the next time
we see him when he becomes the Riddler
but this is kind of a cool moment
because remember when it comes to Edward
nygma he usually has these schemes now
sometimes they're small
sometimes they're huge but before these
schemes happen he pitches out a riddle
and the idea is that if you can figure
out what the answer to the riddle is
you'll save yourself or whoever it is if
you threatening to kill or bring harm to
and this instance is the city of Gotham
but what he does here is he brings out
the riddle of the Sphinx
now the riddle of the Sphinx is actually
this really really cool concept that
dates I think it's I think it's like The
Legend of Oedipus or something along
those lines where they supposedly set
the Sphinx at the entrance to the city
of Thebes and the idea was that if you
could answer the Sphinx's riddle then
you could in turn pass but there are
basically two riddles the first riddle
is really like the most popular of all
the riddles that existed which creature
has one voice and yet becomes four
footed and two footed and then three
footed and the answer to that is
basically a newborn baby which basically
can only just kind of
utter words and then crawls around on
four feet which grows into a man which
walks around on two feet which grows
into an old man and then walks around on
two feet and then uses a cane and so the
second and the least-known riddle is
there are two sisters one gives birth to
the other and she in turn gives birth to
the first one of his two sisters now
we're basically given the answer to this
but here's the thing to keep in mind
while Batman while Bruce Wayne is kind
of interjecting this little bit of
information the idea is that the
Riddler's not really giving the answer
to Gotham City he simply says you know
here's your hint the first sister says
blank and then the second sister says
blank and so again the goal of Gotham is
to figure out the answer to it now the
answer is day and night night gives
birth today which gives birth tonight
again which gives birth today and so on
and so forth just a repeating cycle but
the idea is that the Riddler is
basically taking up this role of
effectively trying to make Gotham City
smarter by calling away those that he
considers to be less intelligent now the
other half of this is that with him
taking down power to the city in its
entirety there's another character here
that we haven't really talked about
before then this is a guy named
Commissioner Loeb this is the guy who's
basically running the show before
Commissioner Gordon takes over that
position the issue with this is that
Batman is still relatively new keep in
mind
Batman's actions within the city of
Gotham were effectively sanctioned by
Commissioner Gordon but only insofar
that he was able to keep the police off
the trail of Batman at this point in the
origin story the two of them aren't
really working together yet and so Bruce
Wayne does not trust Commissioner Gordon
in fact we'll get to that here in a
little bit but the idea is that the
police force for the most part are
turning very much against Batman so it's
really a lot of what you saw if you
watched Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy in the sense that Batman first
shows up and none of the cops trust him
because this is Scott Snyder's Batman
it's not designed to be linear I mean it
is to a degree but it's not designed to
be one of these stories where this
happens and that happens and that
happens and that happens and then we're
done instead Scott Snyder really
interweaves a lot of different things
together which is one of the reasons why
I wanted to go back and just kind of
redo the whole new 52 Batman run which
again you'll find that down in the
playlist up but the idea here is that
with Scott Snyder kind of interweaving
all these different themes what we
actually do is we pick up with this case
where people's bones are just growing
uncontrollably and initially it seems
like it has nothing to do with anything
but again there's a lot of small cameos
that take place here for example Pamela
Isley the woman that will later become
poison ivy you know of course you
basically
points to the idea that she doesn't know
exactly what it isn't went on here but
what she did do is witness a guy that
had basically been sneaking in and out
who looked all skeletal and so it seems
like the kind of point in the finger
that this guy is the one responsible but
again this whole notion of Bruce Wayne
trying to deal with two things at the
same time the idea that Gotham City is
descending into absolute madness in the
absence of the police who are trying to
track down Batman and not dealing with
regular crime as well as this idea that
someone's going around is just causing
all these bodies or these bones to
mutilate to the point where they destroy
people from the inside out this
coincides with him meeting with
Commissioner Gordon now again this is
really one of the only times or one of
the first few times the two of them
actually meet head to head and it's
really just Bruce Wayne saying he does
not trust
Commissioner Gordon now this is
something that's kind of hinted at this
is really done in like three phases the
first phase is this encounter the second
phase is an encounter at a hospital and
the third phase is when Commissioner
Gordon rescues Batman and basically
spills his side of the story and that's
why this is so cool is because it's all
these different themes that are kind of
intertwined and they come together to
create this amazing story but the idea
is the Commissioner Gordon just kind of
shows up on the the grounds of Wayne
Manor not because he knows that Bruce
Wayne is Batman but because he just kind
of you know is looking at Bruce Wayne's
return to Gotham City and the hope that
Bruce Wayne's been espousing in terms of
turning Gotham City around and making it
a better place to live the results of
this is that where Commissioner Gordon
initially begins to sneak around with
the idea that maybe the bat caves down
there or something like that not really
knowing what he's looking for
Bruce Wayne uses a few bruises here and
there it basically says we were just
trying to get rid of bats whatever and
runs Commissioner Gordon out of there
now
at this point we switch over to Lucius
five and this is actually a stark
difference from the Lucius Fox before
the new 52 Lucius Fox originally
appeared back in Batman number 307 in
1979 so he appeared before crisis on
Infinite Earths but the idea here was
that Lucius Fox original employment by
Bruce Wayne came by way of Bruce himself
in the sense that they had basically met
one another and then Lucius Fox was put
in charge of what would become the Wayne
foundation with this new 52 run what
basically happened is this is brought
closer in line with the Dark Knight
trilogy which makes sense because when
people don't see a Batman movie and
they're intrigued and they love it there
has to be some measure of relatability
you have to walk this fine line the
comics have to be different enough that
people aren't basically reading a carbon
copy of what they saw in the
but they have to be similar enough that
they can recognize characters and not
feel totally like removed or unable to
understand what it is it's going on and
so the idea here is we're basically told
about a guy named Halpern now with
regards to Lucius Fox here
he was basically brought on by Bruce
Wayne's father and so that's why he's
really employed here so it's very much
tied into the Christopher Nolan origin
for Lucius Fox himself but the goal here
at least the explanation that's offered
by Lucius is that this guy Helfer and
was basically working on this sort of
nanomedicine in the sense that he could
basically modify the you know organic
structure of bones more or less so the
molecular structure of bones so that if
somebody were to knock you off of a
building you go falling down and the
moment you hit your bones would solidify
to the point that your brain would be
preserved your bones wouldn't break and
you would basically be fine now of
course that raises the question what
would happen if your brain like bounced
off your skull or if your stomach
bounced off your ribcage and just
shattered here just got ripped all the
pieces the long and short of it is that
this would have been revolutionary
technology because and you could start
sending soldiers into the battlefield
without fear of having their bones break
in the middle of skirmishes and
different things like that and this
would even pave the way for things like
bulletproof skin the issue with this is
that Lucius Fox seems to effectively
turn against Bruce Wayne when he makes
the case that finding any measure of
escape from health burn who's basically
being called dr. death now is
essentially impossible and so again it's
really kind of this cool notion because
it seems as though Lucius Fox was either
turned or something along those lines
only for us to find out that you know
with Lucius Fox pacing being attacked by
a by hell furn with Lucius Fox declaring
the name Bruce Wayne only for Helfer to
learn that Bruce Wayne is here which
puts them in a position where you can
basically ransom Bruce or the very least
force verse to basically continue
funding his technology or whatever it is
we end up finding out that with Helfer
and being temporarily incapacitated by
Bruce and allowing himself and Lucius
Fox to get away that Lucius basically
injected him with this sort of basic you
know cure for this illness effectively
now this leads directly into the second
encounter with Bruce Wayne and
Commissioner Gordon and the reason why
is because of the fact that while Bruce
and Lucius are trying to make their
escape Halfin returns again only for
Commissioner Gordon to step in fire a
couple shots and run Helfer and off and
so with regards to Bruce and
Commissioner Gordon's encounter this is
one of the reasons why Snyder's one of
Batman was so cool because it was really
more about the characters than it was
about the story now what we end up
finding out here was that when Bruce
Wayne
was a little kid prior to the death of
his parents really the day his parents
died he had gone for a ride-along with
Commissioner Gordon and the idea was
that Gordon had basically taken him
around to the various parts of Gotham
basically saying this is our location
this is our spot this is where we do you
know our whole thing and monitor the
streets and so on and so forth keep the
things safe but what is up happening
here is basically one of his guys an
officer by the name of Dan really his
partner ends up going into you know a
particular location and then comes out
with this extremely nice looking you
know jacket of sorts this this overcoat
and of course Bruce makes reference to
it asks where did you get this now at
the time the the explanation that was
offered by Commissioner Gordon is well
the citizens of Gotham give this to us
because they love us so much but what
this does is it basically tells Bruce or
at least as he came to realize when he
got older it was effectively a payoff it
was basically bribery is really all it
was instead of cash it was a super nice
coat just a way of saying hey look you
know you look that way you know we'll do
our thing here and you'll get some kind
of a gift in return the result is that
Bruce Wayne he continually harbored
these feelings that Gotham City's Police
Department and Commissioner Gordon were
inherently corrupt and so again you know
grabbing Commissioner Gordon's gun
pointing it at his face he basically
reiterates the feelings that he felt
when his parents were killed and saying
look because of because of Gotham City's
police force because of their
incompetence because of their negligence
because of the fact that they were so
crooked Bruce Wayne's parents were
killed and that's why Bruce does not
like the police department because
you've used the death of his parents as
the failing of the police department and
so the result of this is that with Bruce
going out and basically you know
traveling to one of these little areas
you know basically one of these little
satellite places where he'll friend was
supposedly working out of along with a
few more of his colleagues Commissioner
Gordon also gets us a little bit of a
letter from from Edward nygma now of
course this coincides with the arrival
of Commissioner Commissioner Loeb and
remember like we said Commissioner Loeb
is kind of leading this charge against
Batman basically saying look this guy's
a vigilante this guy doesn't stand for
justice this guy's effectively a villain
we've got to take him out and so what
ensues here is really Batman in one of
us earliest days find difficulty coping
with this situation and that's one of
the reasons why these stories are so
cool is because in the modern day you
know if that were to face off against
the cops it really wouldn't be that
difficult because of his experience and
all of his training really kind of comes
together
I don't allow him to incapacitate the
cops quite readily at this point in his
career he's basically walking a
tightrope
cuz he doesn't have the experience
necessary to understand how to
incapacitate the police while
simultaneously no one being aware of the
fact that he's there now the other half
of this is that Commissioner Loeb and
company were basically tipped off to the
arrival of Batman now of course this
isn't initially given to us instead he
really just kind of dances around him a
little bit he's fired at he's you know
shot a few times were less injured and
of course he manages to make his escape
only to be rescued by Commissioner
Gordon so again this comes into the
third part of Commissioner Gordon and
Bruce Wayne meeting one another now of
course Commissioner Gordon basically
says hey look the Riddler sent out
information to everybody saying what you
were capable of and where you would most
likely go and that's the reason why
Commissioner Lowe but everybody were so
ready for him is because they basically
knew exactly what he was going to do how
he would react now the other half of
this is basically Commissioner Gordon
side of the story with regards to Bruce
Wayne's claims of corruption and what we
end up finding out here is that
Commissioner Gordon was basically three
weeks in Gotham City when he went on
that ride along with Bruce Wayne and for
the most part when he was at this point
in his career having come out of Chicago
where Chicago was an extremely dark and
violent place Commissioner Gordon wanted
to believe that Gotham would be a much
better in a much cleaner place the
problem with this was that Commissioner
Gordon had this sort of feeling under
his gut that there was basically a lot
of corruption taking place in Gotham but
coming out of where he was before
looking out for his daughter looking out
for her son he didn't want to believe it
was true the issue with this was that
when he had given the explanation to
Bruce Wayne that all well the city the
the citizens of Gotham absolutely loved
us when he saw the hope in Bruce Wayne's
face it shattered the illusion and so
what ended up happening here is he
actually end up going out to you know
where he got this jacket from going to
find out that his own partner alongside
a multitude of other police officers as
well as Commissioner Loeb
well basically engaging in these
back-alley dogfighting rings different
things like that they were all on the
take they were engaged in bribery I mean
virtually every illicit act the police
can be engaged in they were engaged in
now of course this leads to things like
if they all got busted it would lead to
like RICO charges I mean it'd be
absolutely insane but the idea here is
the Commissioner Gordon basically says I
went back and I walked my beat you know
these dogs were sicked on me these dogs
attacked me I had to defend myself I
ended up killing him the entire time it
turns out his partner that on Jim Gordon
the wind so even then they were just
betting on whether or not Jim Gordon
list which will help Jim Gordon to rely
that in the face of the Gotham Police
Department it's so corrupt it's totally
irrelevant of a cop lives and dies and
so again you know because of that whole
thing
he basically spills his story to Bruce
Wayne Bruce Wayne and turned bails out
before the story's finished or at least
it seems to be that way now of course
this is really kind of the early stages
of the whole idea where Commissioner
Gordon is talking to that man and that
man just vanishes all of a sudden but
one didn't keep in mind is that Jim
Gordon still does not know that Bruce
Wayne is Batman to him there are two
distinctly different people but the
return of Bruce Wayne forced
Commissioner Gordon to go back and
recall all these old memories that he
had of Bruce and effectively you know
ask himself these serious questions if
you going to be a guy that stands
alongside and watches these cops just
become corrupt or is he going to be a
guy that steps out and actually does
something now of course this leads into
the whole idea of the Riddler's main
scheme and again this is what we kind of
called to see origin of the Riddler's
because this focuses on the Riddler's
nature in the sense that remember like
we said at the beginning of the video
when the Riddler goes into these schemes
big or small you're met with a riddle
if you fail to answer it in time then
you have to pay the price as the idea
here is that Batman basically comes to
the realization that the whole efforts
of Hef burn basically going around and
attacking killing these former
colleagues of his it was not arbitrary
he was not a goal of revenge it was not
him just being angry at those who
rejected him instead he's effectively
working for the Riddler and the reason
why is because of the fact that the
Riddler basically intends to seize
control of Gotham when Powers brought
back up he has effectively tapped into
the the core of the city itself and so
what would end up happening here is that
when the powers taken down it would
result in Gotham light and power so on
and so forth these various agencies to
bringing it back up at the moment that
happens they bring it up under edward
nygma's control and so what isn't
happening here is that the entire city
of Gotham is basically met with a
hurricane now again this hurricane
wasn't like a freak thing no no what
ended up happening is that this
hurricane was on its way and Gotham was
actually prepping for it which is one of
the reasons why Edward nygma chose this
particular scenario because of course
with Batman basically descending on what
he believes to be edward nygma's main
base of operations this giant weather
balloon Batman's realization comes with
the fact that he can basically disrupt
the signal now again this is the idea
that we're Gotham power in light I
thought did we bringing power back up to
the city the Riddler's going to have to
send some kind of a signal out which in
turn Batman can basically interrupt
essentially call it a day and so of
course you're leaping to this this
massive thing one of the things that I
want to point out here is that there is
a panel it's basically a direct homage
to The Dark Knight Returns and it just
looks really cool the way that it's done
it's the small little things like this
that really made us guest letters run
really enjoyable but of course this
leads to Batman basically running back
into health burn again now of course
this coincides with Commissioner Gordon
also tracking down Edward nygma and the
funny thing about this is that Edward
nygma brings up what's called the
Archimedes principle now the Archimedes
principle is this crazy thing in physics
even I don't fully understand it the
overall idea here is this is kind of
like a modified version of the
Archimedes principle in terms of like
buoyancy versus and objects you know
like if you stick your hand and water to
further you stick your hand down the
more pressure you feel on your hand but
the idea is that this is really just
kind of Edward nygma be more Riddler II
I guess if that's a word but it's not
your manes hear that again this
ultimately results in health Bern kind
of telling a story and what we find out
here is that he hails from a family that
had largely been involved in different
wartime conflicts going as far back as
World War two the problem with this is
that this psychological break that
happened with him came in multiple
stages the first was really like the
death of his son in the Middle East the
second was being fired from his job at
Wayne Enterprises because his views on
nano medicine were so extreme and the
third was basically coming to the
realization and there seemed to be no
way for him to be able to achieve his
goal because he was fired from Wayne
Enterprises now this led to the Riddler
engaging in actions that would basically
help help earn by funding his research
so on and so forth but again all this is
because of the fact that Edward nygma
wasn't trying to achieve his own goal
now with regards to health burn for the
most part while Batman tries to reason
with him and say hey look you know
you're being used by the Riddler health
friend doesn't really care the end
result is that even if he dies his
research will be studied and catalogued
and his legacy will live on this is one
of the reasons why his character is so
dramatic and why his character is kind
of crazy out there is because it's not
necessarily about what a man can achieve
in his lifetime it's about what a man
can do to live beyond his own death into
the future of humanity and so what ends
up happening here is that in this
skirmish between the two of them Batman
comes to the realization that health
burns limbs basically continue to grow
and expand in response to trauma meaning
that if you can basically go through and
start breaking off bones that his bones
will just start growing and essentially
replace them now the problem with this
is that the formulas
we broken and it's not perfect what
would happen if the formula was perfect
it that I would come along and he would
break his femur bone for example he just
kick him in the thigh really hard and
break his femur and the bone would heal
perfectly with this imperfect formula
Batman would break off a piece of the
bone and then all the bones in the body
would just start regrowing and so again
there's no rhyme or reason to why it
happened the issue with this is that it
basically causes the bones within the
body of Helper to start to start growing
uncontrollably
and this results in Batman both
destroying this you know weather balloon
basically as well as health burns a
skull growing to the point where it
actually just crushes his brain but dark
city basically comes to a close when the
power is brought back up and all they
see is just a Riddler question mark
which of course means that the Riddler
now has control of the city detonating
this trigger more or less he ends up
detonating all these safety walls around
the city of Gotham which basically
allows water to just come pouring in and
effectively begin the process of
drowning almost everybody in Gotham
proper so again this is why I say the
new 52 Riddler was so cool and so
interesting because for the most part I
wouldn't say I'm an expert on the
Riddler before the new 52 but I don't
really recall his schemes being as big
and grandiose as this but it's still a
pretty cool thing to see him basically
try to destroy the entire city of Gotham
and only those smart enough to either
seek safety or those smart enough to
figure out the riddle but ultimately be
the ones who would find some measure of
help and survive to see the next day but
without being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come as explained
and make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like ah next one is today
Tuesday next Tuesday is going to be
Savage City which brings a conclusion to
the Batman's you or your story arc and
that will effectively let us just kind
of wait until the war jokes and riddles
finishes but I'll go ahead and throw
this video down in the playlist so you
guys can stay up to date on everything
that's going on and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]